so from timcast.com Twitter accounts
will not be reinstated until new content
moderation Council convenes says Elon
Musk he says Twitter will be forming a
Content moderation council with widely
diverse viewpoints no major content
decisions or account reinstatements will
happen before that Council convenes
let me just break this down for all you
guys
first it is a victory a tremendous
victory that Elon Musk has purchased
Twitter I'm glad to see that something
good is happening but Elon
like us is making a mistake
earlier on in the show in a previous
segment photos that are just tuning in
for those Justinian we mentioned that
the person who attacked Paul Pelosi at
the Pelosi house was a leftist we also
wanted to mention that he does have a
bunch of weird conspiracies as a nudists
and it's probably just a crazy person
meanwhile leftists are trying to claim
he's a Maga guy because he denied the
election and posted Q stuff at any
moment in every moment the left will
outright just be like it's Maga Marjorie
Taylor green said we won't forget the
companies that stopped donating because
of 2020 and a prominent Twitter leftist
said this is a direct threat and it's
why Pelosi got attacked blah blah blah
they go to the extreme end Elon Musk is
telling us right now he's going to
invite them
to sit down and discuss how to handle
censorship you see before Elon bought
Twitter he said the appropriate solution
should be where there's a compromise and
everyone's a little unhappy but he
doesn't realize the conservatives the
independence and Libertarians
post-liberals have already compromised
saying outright we accept the left will
say naughty words we just want to be
able to express our opinions the left
then says we want you banned and we can
do whatever we want there's no
compromise there because you've got one
side that already compromised and the
left saying to everything or nothing if
Elon Musk is going to form a a a
moderation Council and invite the woke
left Indigo but my feelings are hurt
when he said I was ugly then he's gonna
go all right well let's give the left a
little bit of what they want the only
problem that is literally what Vegeta
and Jack Dorsey did Jack Dorsey and
Vijaya were basically running Twitter
like okay conservatives don't care that
left us are on the platform they won't
leave so we don't have to do anything
for them their content but the left will
leave unless we banned some
conservatives here's the compromise we
don't ban all of the conservatives only
a few to make the left think we're doing
something and then the right won't leave
because we're not Banning everybody
that's the problem this will not work
it's a bad move and Elon needs to go in
now independently of his own volition
and release the political prisoners and
he needs to accept he is responsible for
this and there's no diverse Viewpoint
that's going to solve the problem amen
and I hope this is just fluff to cover
you know his tracks from a PR
perspective for any next moves but he
has to come out guns blazing you know
open up the prison cells release
everybody and just overwhelm the left
with all the reforms and changes he's
gonna make because if he starts doing a
piecemeal they're gonna just attack it
piecemeal and they're going to divide
and conquer and it's going to be this
messy drawn out situation with this
ridiculous fluffy sounding Council which
honestly sounds no different than things
they've done in the past it's exactly
what they already were doing yeah if
you're going to build a council don't
build the Council of people to decide
who gets banned and who gets unbanned
get a council of people to decide how to
build a system so that the Bannings and
unbannings can happen judiciously right
nothing good comes out of committee tell
us about minds the mind's jury system is
legitimate I think this is the way to go
and so what happens is if you're on
mines and your stuff gets flagged uh
someone in the administrative team will
be like okay that they got flagged they
got banned and then if you don't agree
you appeal it it goes to people that
have opted in on mines to the jury
system like up to 12 or more random
people get the content it says does this
violate the terms of service then they
have an opportunity to swipe right or
swipe left if they're on their phone or
whatever say yes or no if it violates it
or if it doesn't so if enough people say
yeah it violates it you're still banned
you can appeal it maybe twice you can
three times uh if you say no it doesn't
violate it you get a majority of people
then it's unbanned and then if it gets
flagged again goes back through the
process now if someone if a jury member
is saying it doesn't violate the terms
but it does and they keep repeatedly
doing that on things that keep coming up
and they keep getting it wrong they
eventually lose their their ability to
be on the journey that shouldn't happen
I disagree because I think people will
abuse it what they'll do is they'll vote
how they want it I want it to be on the
site but that's not what I'm asking I'm
asking if it violates the terms jury
nullification is exactly I think this
shouldn't be illegal and I won't convict
someone well notification needs to exist
and hold on the reason why I think
that's a bad move a bad element of it is
that let's say the platform becomes
dominated by really awful people who
want to see free speech ban Wikipedia
and there's a hand exactly and a handful
of people are saying this didn't break
the rules why are you saying it did and
then all of a sudden Minds comes down
and says look the majority has repeat
repeatedly said you're wrong so we're
removing you well then what would happen
the scent must be allowed I think what
would happen is an admin at mines would
review if if like a bunch of people are
saying it's not violating it's not but
it is and then you're like okay who are
all these accounts that keep saying it's
not violating why do they keep saying
it's not what it is
violent when it doesn't it sounds good
on paper but this is how Wikipedia
devolved and you have this this
organized ideologically driven minority
maybe on that platform that decides the
edits that approves the edits that
controls the entire editing hierarchy it
will be taken over Fabian style but the
argument is because it's a random
selection of jurors every time but
there's no there's no um cabal right but
you can't punish a juror for giving
their honest thoughts you can downrank
their no that's their ability if they're
not accurate No this needs to be not
absolutely not I think so it's a private
company make it a dictator imagine
imagine if we said in public in a
legitimate criminal trial you're like
this guy is not guilty and like well
everyone else said he was you must be
wrong we're not going to let you be on a
jury trial anymore that is insane well
this is you have a civic duty right if
it's illegal it's off it's off the site
I mean that's an illegal thing and
someone's saying it's legal then I don't
think they should be a juror
I I I understand that but that means you
have to review every single person
whether they said it was good or bad or
you can algor you can algorithmically
calculate people that are inaccurate and
then just over time downrank is the holy
spirit again but the algorithm would be
public it would be like a free software
algorithm that you can go on GitHub and
look at so so the facts matter here when
it comes to this particular case and
there's a lot of other things happening
uh behind the scenes there's a lot of
things happening with a coordinated
media push right now to try to get
advertisers off of Twitter but uh Elon
Musk just 20 minutes ago tweeted that
there have been no changes to the
Twitter content moderation policies he
also tweeted today that quote comedy is
now legal on Twitter Michaela Peterson
responded to him and asked hey can can
you get my father back on the platform
and he said specifically quote anyone
suspended for minor and dubious reasons
will be freed from Twitter jail that's a
direct comment from Elon Musk on his
official Twitter account now let's
Factor this in a lot of people have been
banned on Twitter a crap ton of them
would you you want to be the one solely
responsible looking at that list saying
okay okay okay no this guy did something
bad here going through all the history
here I wouldn't want that recipe I
wouldn't want that job this is why he's
announcing some kind of counsel how will
he handle it it's going to be
interesting I just hope he's not being
swayed by The Washington Post that by
the way uh again I talked about this
yesterday Bill Gates literally is
putting money into organizations to
launch attacks on Twitter right now
pressure he has been doing this and and
has been planning this for months The
Washington Post came out today and is
telling people how to turn off their
advertisements on their settings on
Twitter so they could sabotage Twitter
and of course the money that they get
from advertisers GM just announced that
their temporary suspending ads on
Twitter what will happen moving forwards
well I'm still optimistic his tweets are
saying he's going to to to make sure
that he's going to undelete the censored
people on on social media including
people like Jordan Peterson I'm hopeful
I think he's going to do it but I think
it's going to take time he needs to hold
the line he needs to realize it's going
to be tough in the beginning obviously
with the advertisers the pressure
campaigns Etc but they have nowhere else
to go from an advertising perspective
they're going to come back this was
never going to be a financially
lucrative deal at least not for a long
for the long run Twitter was never
making money so the advertising is just
sort of putting off some of the
financial losses that the company's
suffering but at the end of the day he
needs to come out he needs to be bold he
needs to unban these people immediately
and if he Dilly dallies if he Dithers
they're going to smell blood they're
going to jump on it and they're going to
come after him and his reputation's on
the line because he you know this was a
massive ordeal that he undertook and you
know I think I agree with everyone here
it's going to be better no matter what
on the margins but if he backs off and
he doesn't fulfill it I mean he's going
to look like a total fool I mean he's a
TOEFL he owns the company it's private
he has full dictatorial Powers
effectively to set these standards he
could you know devolve some power to
some stupid counsel but the end of the
day he should come out set the standards
set the the maximum from everything to
follow and if they follow it good and if
they don't follow it well he has other
problems or at least I hope you're wrong
but but I I kind of agree with you that
he should at least do the basic ones
Jordan Peterson project Veritas that's
going to be a Babylon B I mean just
those Basics alone are clear obvious you
don't need a committee and a commission
to to figure out that that was
absolutely wrong for those people to be
censored right and the people down the
hierarchy you know these minor accounts
these no-name people that were banned
for a variety of reasons that's going to
be more complex and it's probably going
to take a lot of time and Logistics fine
we all understand that but it takes all
five minutes like you said to look at
Jordan Peterson and say okay bring it
back on Elon crossed the Rubicon
he he declared war on the cathedral
they've run and in panic and he's taken
Rome it is now his Empire
he needs to just accept what he's done
and make the changes he wants to make I
don't understand why he would not
immediately reinstate The Babylon be
everyone knows he did this because of
the Babylon be the Babylon bee did
literally nothing wrong he said comedy
is allowed once again the first thing he
could have done and if I was Elon I'd
take my phone I'd press record I'd walk
in the front doors of Twitter I'd look
at the camera and go hey guys hey who
works here unban The Babylon B I'm
filming get it done now I'm counting I'm
glad you made the Cesarean reference
because Caesar came into Rome and was
forgiving and you know gave everyone a
second chance and then Brutus you know
stabbed him in the back and the rest of
the Senate so he cannot go into Rome and
take this Caesarean approach that he's
going you know love his enemies and give
everyone a second chance all the
optimates and the and the Senators and
the rest of the Twitter Twitter audio
Elite he needs to come in with an Iron
Fist and crack some skulls and just make
it clear that this is the new law of the
land and we're not backing down and they
will they will back off but at the same
time if he does something he's going to
have thousands of people come to him
what about me what about me can you do
me can you do me can you do me and
that's a lot of pressure from a lot of
powerful people that were censored
incorrectly he's only one guy he needs
15 minutes in between you know what I
mean I think you come into Rome you
immediately lay out your new
Constitution and then give the power to
the people to govern themselves we don't
even we don't even need to agree
protocol with jury system uh
um constitutional values unban anyone
that didn't violate U.S Lawns wherever
the headquarters San Francisco is the
headquarters it doesn't violate
California state law then unbanned right
from the beginning then you decide if
you need to ban them for terms of
services so also all the terms of
service are going to change now
right that's well yeah the misgendering
policies got to go not every word but
it's up to Eli he can be as creative as
he wants with in terms it's this simple
check out the mind's terms make it a
protocol give yourself access to the
real estate
make the real estate sellable the
advertising real estate as an as a
commodity or asset on a public protocol
and then you you effectively give
yourself you make it worth substantially
more money you remove moderation
requirements from you and say if someone
look here's the way I describe it if
Coca-Cola buys a billboard in Times
Square and then I go stand in front of
it holding up a sign with a picture of
something really awful
is Coca-Cola going to call up their ads
that buyer and be like hey are their ad
seller and be like oh well why is there
a man standing in front of my sign
saying naughty words they're gonna be
like because he's standing on a public
Street next question what's white
wasting my time we should not be looking
at Twitter in this way if if you want to
advertise where the conversation is
happening you recognize people say
things you don't like period right they
make it a protocol they make it
interoperable with other platforms they
remove their ability to moderate
anything and say law enforcement can
handle it and also with the advertising
I mean this was a dying platform this is
mostly used by journalists certain
niches of society it's not this Mass
public platform like an Instagram or
even a snap or even a a tick tock it is
a platform for you know different
degrees of Elites essentially talking to
other Elites and then a few people
liking it the advertisers will come when
he creates when he turns it back into a
platform that people want to be on
people want to engage in have engaging
people and it's not this controlled
manipulated bot infested platform which
it is now which is and he bought it
extremely overvalued so he turns it back
to what it should be the advertisers
will return and any political
disagreements they have in the interim
will be you know things of the past I
actually posted an old video of Elon
Musk talking about Twitter making fun of
I I posted this on my shorts on my
YouTube channel which people get to
watch I definitely recommend you watch
that because Elon Musk talked about his
plans for Twitter he talked about how
it's absolutely crazy that it took
Twitter one year to work on something
like an edit button right he then went
on it was like you know we should make
this like WeChat and then and WeChat is
something that's not really popular here
in the United States but in places like
China everyone depends on WeChat for
virtually almost every aspect of their
life and existence you do everything on
WeChat and this is the type of vision
that he has that he might transform and
change Twitter to 2X and again Twitter
made some horrible absolutely idiotic
decisions when it came to their business
they run owned Periscope they ruined
Vine they had the tick tock before Tick
Tock even existed Tick Tock right now is
dominating all the social media
platforms with so many users with so
much engagement with so much uh just
short-term uh gratification for a lot of
individuals whether it's good or bad
that's debatable but but YouTube and and
but excuse me Twitter had that live
streaming ability had that Tick Tock
ability and they just threw it in the
trash they deprecated everything it's
been a history of deprecating features
refusing to release features it's it's
interesting than the last year with
Twitter blue with the edit button with a
whole Litany of other features it's all
come out of you know the Woodworks
because up until then it was just a
series that they had fleets for a while
I remember yeah I got rid of fleets that
was a little it was they literally had
Vine they had the opportunity to be the
number one Marketplace video service
right now they had they could have been
it and arguably if you make a comparison
to Facebook if Facebook had not acquired
Instagram Facebook would be done by now
I mean Facebook its platform is is dying
it's Instagram that keeps it afloat had
Twitter successfully kept AI they would
be in a totally different position to
that thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there